ja leute dann möchte ich jetzt auflösen
also die auflösung unterstand ist servus
s kids und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge minecraft und heute wird es
die lange ersehnte auflösung geben als
allererstes gucken dass wir diese runde
bisschen klarkommen jeder spieler ist
828 max ist die praxis mit dem start
okay ich spiele heute zum ersten mal als
ich spiele heute zum ersten mal
überhaupt in meinem ganzen leben auf
boni aufrief ich hab das zum neuen
server entdeckt komme hde kennt ihn
schon erstmal etwas auf reserve also
advanced abo tv kompromiss in sicht ich
kneife denen die täter lassen sind ins
hotel es gibt ein paar gute sachen unter
anderem nun fallschirm für zwei gold nur
als werbe spreche jetzt hier sehen sie
den fallschirm für lediglich zwei gold
also fast nur zwei gold- und runter
jumpen und dann spawn zu schicken an
deinem kopf mit dem du ihn schicken
geschwindigkeit runterfällt
ach so viele falsche vorfalls in der
mitte ganz in der mitte von dieser blume
ganz in der mitte und ansonsten gefällt
aufbäumen paar wenige trip die andere
sachen aber ansonsten ist alles gleich
neues er leute übrigens ich werde euch
am ende der heutigen folge die auflösung
geben sich für den ersten märz
besprochen ob die auflösung von 25k
spende wird es irgendwann am ende geben
ich werde dich nicht so machen dass es
genau am ende ist und ich wette es weil
ich ein ganz lustiger und geschickter
und tino focke belästigung verstecken
das heißt bleibt einfach erlebt
ja was ist gesagt ich finde chip im ball
okay er will also in zwölf nehmen die
coverage korrekt flap xp10 direkt zu
kritik weil er unter ich hab viel gold
ich sollte in diesen viel gold jetzt
hier nicht runterfallen okay bis zu
konzentrieren
viel holz das beste aller zeiten hast du
dich sofort mitgenommen
ich hab mich zurück zu sein
wir müssen schon passiert eine
mannschaft das ist halt und max kelly
na jetzt kommunikation ist und mexiko 8
update die welt ist war mario canori wie
kann ich nur dankeschön der dealer ist
immer bei mir war es gerade steve ja
manchmal ist die fonds gehen deshalb
ganz normal skin base also die
andauernden kriege laden merkels den
typen von team grün rad in die mitte
die schau ist bisschen anders habe ich
also dass so ein bisschen wie wenn man
sagen wenn nicht kannst du direkt wie
aufgaben und teilweise ein bisschen
brücke zweiten silberling es in dem
wasser ein zimmer raster noch drin ist
wo ja gut leute ok hill gesagt ich sage
zum ersten mal heute auf dem papier war
aber du musst du unbedingt mal kaufte
ihm ein fallschirm wald ist echt der
hammer also die umsetzung des mega der
bionische gewonnen drei runden das von
drei minuten drei rhythmus 3
die runde war so schnell ist man einfach
drei runden und drei runden gedauert die
runde
ok nächste runde das bist du viel ich
bin halt einfach einem dreierteam zweier
karte wie heißt du
ich bin mit snap sohn youtube & friedman
ja wir sind an beiden im dreier-team auf
eine zweitkarte was red back down wie
sushi wir sind so schnell gedreht und
kuba wir werden einfach nicht angezeigt
auf der karte okay okay leute und ich
hab noch auf seine sitzen siehst du
nicht wie heißt du ich es jetzt bin ich
bin tot
ich will dieses verklärten ende noch
verlieren
okay okay ein paar wollte wollte ich
spende verlieren heute und zwar okay es
geht los
ja ich habe ja gesagt erst im märz ist
die deadline und das hat sich jetzt
wieder neue sachen ergeben mit dem
spender und ich habe einfach gesagt
leute ich hab ich versprochen am ersten
märz kommt die info und wenn ich sowas
sagen wir ja zu meinem wort stehen
ich finde ich wichtig dass man das macht
deswegen kommt jetzt heute dieses video
in dem ich euch sage die aktuelle lage
ist und das ist so ich wollte einfach
dass ich will es einfach mal irgendwie
loswerden wenn man diese sache viele
fragen in den kommentaren ja immer
dieselben fragen alle dazu und ja es ist
einfach so zu sagen immer das gleiche
thema das auf dauer bisschen leidlich
ist wenn man
wann immer die gleichen fragen
beantworten muss sozusagen alles war ja
aber wie gesagt ich hatte ja gesagt
erster märz ist die deadline am ersten
märz gebe ich euch eine endgültige info
und gleichauf wie es aussieht damit ihr
nicht immer fragen müssten wir
willkommen wir bauen uns informiert
darüber dass das wäre ja gleich baut
damit am ende silber einsammeln kann da
kannst du dann das in der mitte
irgendwie weg bauen oder so geschickt
irgendwie ja jetzt auch das geht auf den
fall weiter ja ja ja und gewaltseiten
und die beste entscheidung
er hätte in der neuen kategorie image
muss man tun sie jetzt keine partner
mehr zum glück nicht okay okay okay des
kritischen stellen okay ich habe auf
jeden fall auch hier gut holz weida ist
in die ich habe auf jeden fall jetzt ins
bett abgebaut von einem team hier von
einem anderen team ok doch nicht ja ist
alles ist in ordnung und ich finde es in
ordnung
ich finde es in ordnung
ok krass ich war einfach garten der
gegnerischen base hat mir sobald deren
sehen ob ich etwas geholt lauf rein
zudem die darsteller durch den
messerstich erhält bist du denkst du
eigentlich kümmert es ob es wirklich
marxist und haut ihn einfach ist ein
gegner den hab ich einfach rausgeworfen
gehört das bett von tim roth zerstört
und einen von ihnen sogar direkt mit
nice jetzt gibt's noch grün grün grün
grün sind alle meine knollen meine allem
eine remix meine du dem team zum bunten
dem berühmten hatte ich dich karten da
brauchen wir einfach zu wenig wenn die
blöcke hier ja all diese die
angelegenheit mit der spende ja die
schalter
die leute mögen nicht so den überblick
wie einfach teilweise so raus also die
stehen irgendwo einen kanal kassel
account
okay dass ihr weg gebaut ist eine gute
sache bei hey joe kannst du
ich bin über die west blöcke droppen
das willst du hingehen können bleibt er
stehen hier zwölf gold 7 12 gold damit
sollte ich jetzt vielleicht nicht
riskieren darüber drehen
macon den oder ok es gibt nur den
eigenen alles da noch google co ich
glaube es ist auch schon leute und dann
ist ja jetzt auch schon soweit am ende
dass ich euch schon mal sagen kann da
also blöcke getroffen ich habe ja da
unten da unten jetzt gegessen mit seinem
outfit wie krass die leute dann möchte
ich jetzt auflösen
also die auflösung unterstand ist es
folgendermaßen die 25k sind nicht
angekommen das sind 150 die bullock mehr
gespendet hat
150 euro für die nicht für die ich sehr
dankbar bin und zwei monitore die er mir
geschickt hat so wie er sagt momentan
die noch unterwegs sind
das ist sozusagen alles aber wie gesagt
dennoch bin ich sehr dankbar für diese
spende die hat mir auch im letzten monat
viel geholfen
zu den 25 da kommt es aber nicht so wie
er es selbst gesagt hat weil er
irgendwie keine ahnung sagte dass jetzt
nämlich nicht mehr so eine planung im
wie was hat er gesagt nicht mehr so
fällt nicht unterstützenswert oder so
irgendwas war der wortlaut irgendwie
oder irgendwelche leute hätten was
erzählt über mich und das phantom cool
keine ahnung auf jeden fall habe dieser
runde auch gerade gewonnen ja also 25
kann 150 euro wurden gespendet darf noch
mal danke schön und im vita monitor die
ich jetzt aber auch noch nicht da sind
eventuell unterwegs
das ist alles was ich momentan dazu
sagen kann sollte ich irgendwann etwas
neues geben werde im laufenden halten
das ist vorerst erstmal die endgültige
info wenn irgend jemand fragt leitet ihn
gerne weiter was ich euch jetzt wie
gesagt habe oder verweis auf das video
und ja das ist alles was ich sagen kann
max in der beschreibung check-in gerne
mal ab wir sehen uns vom nächsten video
video 3